first ever appearance against the
seattle mariners four-one left-hander
core urban who makes his 10th start of
the season at three and five record as a
result of his last start against the
houston astros in which he and the
athletics lost the interesting thing
about him there's dallas about this uh
throughout the game early part of the
game fly ball out 11.
that was against uh tampa bay then he
had 10 ground ball outs against
the twins and then
10 fly ball outs in his last car so back
and forth now the mariners have two on
its scoring position with two outs
looking to cash in early the banner will
be first baseman ty france swinging a
ground ball wide at third diving off the
glove of the third baseman pinder no
play and a run will score
hanukkah will score from third the
mariners have a one nothing lead on an
infield base hit by ty france pinder
diving to his left it hit off his glove
bounced to his left the short stop
andrews couldn't get to it because he
was backing up on the play
so haniger scores the mariners lead at
one to nothing lewis will get to third
and france is on at first base with an
infield single and a run batted in
crawford swung on line drive into center
field for a base hit here comes lewis on
to score and the mariners have a
two-nothing lead j.p crawford continues
his consistent hitting drives in a run
with two outs
guy lewis going easily and it's two
nothing mariners here in the top of the
first and ty france will get to second
but jp jumping on that first pitch had a
rocket right back up the middle
crawford has lashed 40 ball games
hitting
275. while the mariners hand young
right-hander logan gilbert a very quick
two-nothing lead as we go to the bottom
of the first inning gilbert
just 24 years of age out of winter park
florida getting ready for his third
major league start
marcano will lead things off for the a's
he'll be followed by
seth brown and then center fielder ramon
lauriano as he gets away with one right
there center cut at 94. can a good
fastball hit her whips up so two up and
two down mariners lead two nothing here
is center fielder ramon loreano slider
swing and a miss by l'oreal for strike
three a couple of strikeouts for logan
gilbert and he takes care of the a's one
two three here in the bottom of the
first inning we go to the top half of
the second eight nine and one it's
murphy mayfield and kellnick here's the
fish to him and he swings in linesman
and pinder makes a great backhanded stab
on a fair ball back at third that ball
was drilled by murphy and pinder reacts
to the backhand would have been a fair
ball if it had dropped
and that's at number one
we've already seen chad pinder's
instincts on display here early on
another very quick reactional play here
this just goes to show
why bob melvin has the confidence of
putting him
in anywhere go stand wherever you want
chad take whatever glove you want we
know you can do it wherever we put you
it's two nothing in favor of the
mariners lead off double by olsen we're
in the bottom of the second and here's
the fish to get and swung on it drilled
the left center up the alley and
nobody's there and that's going to go to
the wall crashing off the wall scoring
is olson and pulling up at second with a
double as lowry and the athletics cut
the mariners lead down to 2-1 boy that
was thrilled almost drilled a hole
in the wall out there halfway up the
wall in left center olsen scored easily
and jed has another double
and his 27th run batted in
and that'll bring up tony kemp there's a
line drop base in right field
here comes lowry hanniger's throw to the
plate is just a little bit late and up
the line and this game is tied thanks to
a two-out rbi hit by tony kent tony
campos offline drive base hits it right
scoring lowry from second
it's a 2-2 ball game in the bottom of
the second there's two on the ace two
one on and one out for the mariners
that'll bring up catcher tom murphy out
to left field driven back way back off
the wall nearly gone
crawford is steaming around tom murphy
blisters one off the fence
and has put the mariners in front three
to two in the fourth inning jp crawford
scoring easily from second base
so the mariners have the lead three to
two cannon going back
took a leap but it was well over his
head
up against that tall wall just to the
right of the out of town scoreboard here
with the oakland coliseum
keller has hit the ball hard twice
already tonight good looking hitter
here's the stretch next offer on the way
swinging the brown ball the first diving
try olson gets behind him for a base hit
murphy running third heading home he's
being waved in down the stretch he comes
and he scores on a base into right field
by jared kellnick and the mariners now
lead the a's four to two celtics second
base hit of the night and his fifth rbi
in the big leagues and now the a's have
the tying runs aborted first and second
with one out here in the bottom of the
fifth swinging a fly ball to the center
feeling deep lewis having to flag it
down and make the catch
deep in center field robbing laureato of
a base hit the runners head on back what
a catch by kyle lewis deep in center
field outruns the baseball with a leap
at the end of the run what a big time
play by number one at center field he
had to cover a lot of ground he was out
towards right center here's elvis
andrews just two for two in the game
swinging a mass he got him
nice pitch bearing in at 96.
is nasty
away here comes the pitch
swung on popped up this is playable just
off the infield under is crawford on the
grass waiting for it drops out of the
oakland night sky makes the catch and
that's another one two three inning and
the count is one and two on right
fielder seth brown the stretch and the
two two on the way swing and it's popped
up
left side of the mound chagua wants it
calling for it and chagra will make the
catch eric campbell the third baseman
with a shift on was way over toward the
bag in the picture
jt chargois says you know what i got a
glove on i can catch this and he does
so brown pops it up to the pitcher one
out
for the a's here in the bottom of the
eighth inning jt with a big smile on his
face lefty on lefty with olson
lauriano's at second and here's the
pitch to olson high inside gets away
from murphy lariano's going to third the
throw he dives he's safe the ball goes
over the head of the third baseman
campbell and lauriano will score
and it's four to three seattle the ball
gets away from murphy the catcher that
scored a wild pitch
loriana racing at third the throw by tom
murphy
trying to cut down loriana with third
airmail the third baseman eric campbell
and lariano seeing that easily scored
and now the a's are down by
just a long run in the bottom of the
eighth here's sean murphy one on two
outs a run in four three mariners
clocked
out to deep right center field hannigar
hey makes the catch
robs sean murphy of an extra base in and
he saves a run the inning is over holy
smokes what a catch by mitch haniger
first and third two outs
and the batter is seth brown montero
harpoons it and he will take it all the
way to first base
and lock down a mariners win and a
series victory at the coliseum